so tell what does success mean to you
it's really being able to be honest with
clients and create great work I'm here
with Todd hunter who's the creative
executor or the creative executive at
CAA creative executive and what for
people who don't know what advertising
how it works what does your exactly mean
sure it means from concept to strategic
insight all the way through to creation
and distribution I manage an idea and I
tell stories on behalf of our clients
and hopefully to solve a problem so you
come up with ideas on be happier your
client comes to you with the problem you
know
I'm Michael Nouri I feel under
advertised Jordan you're gonna help me
discover what my brand is and what I'm
trying to say so how does that creative
process work
sure it all starts hopefully with a
great creative brief a great assignment
from a client you know and whether
that's launch a search engine like we
did with Bing or you know tell the story
of food with integrity for Chipotle
it starts with what we're trying to
achieve and then from there you know I
work in an incredibly wonderfully
collaborative environment with other
creative professionals
fortunately working at CIA with agents
and motion picture and television and so
it's about tapping into that ecosystem
and finding little things little
insights little stuff that you want to
bring into the world and you want to
make to help solve that problem that you
think will connect with the audience
you're trying to reach tell me a little
bit more about the Chipotle campaign
this is a big deal for you right sure
yeah absolutely it was exciting to be a
part of that work there's no question
about it
our first meeting with them was with
Steve ELLs the CEO and Founder Monty the
co CEO Mark crumb packer the CMO and
three of us sat down with them and just
explained what CA I did and they told us
about their problem and their problem
was that for 17 years they had been
creating and pulled he's been around for
17 17 almost 20 now actually yeah it's
between at the time of 17 years asleep
you know they're they're growing still
you know they're still relatively small
compared to even what I think their
impression would be in them they have
about a 1,100 stores 1,200 stores across
the nation which compared to McDonald's
is 10,000 is over and the thing about
Chipotle was that they had been changing
food culture dramatically but nobody
knew about it they were sourcing Neyman
ranch beef and going to free-range pork
and locally purchased produce from
farmers more
gets by their managers that day and no
one knew this story and and we were so
shocked so to be able to tell that story
it was incredible and the leading piece
we did to create that was this hopefully
thought-provoking statement on the state
of our food industry for a fast casual
restaurant to take on such a lofty idea
was fun and inspiring and you want some
awards for that right we did humbly so
just about every award and advertise
like I think we won the ones I'm most
excited about of course does the can
Grand Prix for film as well as the first
Grand Prix for Brandon entertainment and
content and that's really exciting to
see the can festival recognizing work
that's kind of in a new medium because
that's really what you know I personally
loved and invested in what we do at CI a
and you also want to heads edge you
should see now this is an interesting
thing I always ask people I know in the
advertising it can advertising be
informative as much as as well as sell I
mean I didn't have a social beneficial
effect I think you see a lot of them I
think the best ads do the best ads and
the best content is is thought-provoking
and is stands for something that's
larger than the brand and larger than
selling itself and if you look at the
brands that are really great that people
talk about over times you look at Nike
very little of what they do is about the
shoe at the end of the day right it's
about something far greater and that was
a work with Chipotle as well what do you
what are you working on now working on
the next chapter of our Chipotle work
which is exciting we're going up to
three festivals in the coming year we do
this thing called the cultivate festival
which is chefs and musicians getting
together and 30,000 people at a time
we're working on the next animated film
with a great directing studio called
moonbots studios they won the Academy
Award last year for animated short so
it's really exciting work working with a
MacArthur Foundation Oh interesting yeah
yeah right very different for them
actually we're working with their
digital media and learning group which
is all about how to get kids inspired to
geek out and mess around with the stuff
that they love so making things together
as groups and since we have kind of an
expertise in how to communicate popular
culture they came to us on how they
reach youth better and how to create
things they're excited to participate in
really we don't have time for really two
more questions sure no first one it's
like where do you see yourself in five
years how does this evolve I mean now
you'll be running your own agency who do
you want to stay did you know I know I
love CIA that's for sure it's my home I
grew up there been there for six years
now and for me the work leads me to
where I go
so wherever I'm creating the best work
possible and right now there's no better
place for me to be at CIA and crew make
keep making things that aren't the
normal you know very few places right to
create a festival one day and do a
fashion collaboration the next and then
create an animated film with pigs and
song by Willie Nelson and it's kind of a
special little playground I get to work
in so the last question for young star
in advertising in New York City's you're
like resembled madman you know what
actually surprisingly and strangely so
in weird ways you know working at CIA
it's probably the most formal
advertising environment in the world
people are in type really actually the
people in suits and three-piece suits
every day in beautiful stunning offices
and there's a strange Mad Men era about
it in that regard